I made a promise to Eric and then I
completely went back on that yesterday I
played the title Tuesday I was analyzing
the Stafford Gambit
before the tournament no you weren't
yeah I was and then I realized that
white wind would like any move
and like I I don't want to diss Eric's
opening but I couldn't bring myself to
play it it was just like I couldn't
analyze it every move wins it was
terrible to go back on a promise like
that
betray me when there is actual proof
that he made the promise uh next title
Tuesday I'm going to play this stuff
again okay so that's a promise I did
something bad
I did something that hurt a friend
I made a promise to
Eric Rosen and I I broke that promise
I need to make up for that so we'll do
something tomorrow
[Music]
oh did Fabiano play the Stafford
did that happen wow faviano
living up to his promise
playing a Stafford
I'm no longer so broken
wow this is historic
I think Fabiano is probably the highest
rated player ever online
to play soccer Gambit
but let's see let's see how he did
Bishop C5 Bishop E2 H5
oh he's following our game oh that's so
funny I covered exactly this line
and
uh in in the drama video that I made but
this is the exact line that he played
against me
in our game a couple weeks ago
and okay he plays H5
Knight G4 wow this is all prep
Bishop F4 maybe it's already out of prep
but let's see how uh
a super Grand Master
treats this position
I like it I mean this is usually what I
do I usually like to go for this idea
let's see what he goes for
B6 what is B6
oh V6 new idea I don't understand this
move
I guess he's just trying to play solidly
ah A5 so gradually storming not going
for this Rook lift 92 A4 okay
Alpha zero style saves the bishop pair
centralizes a rook B5
nice structure
he's got a nice kind of
solid setup going on on the queen side
G5 wow he's really using his Pawns
to their full potential two sets of
double Pawns
okay some trade he's still down the pawn
but that's the magic of the staffer and
you're down the pawn
give the point in a false sense of
confidence
now the queen and Bishop are aligned but
the knight's really solid
wow D5
ooh
oh he wins back the pawn
that's a key Pawn too and now boxes has
better structure
C6 could move C6 defended The Rook with
the bishop
oh and he goes up upon he probably
played this move and then said oh no my
Bishop but the queen takes d8 Queen H1
and White's getting back rank mated that
Bishop covers a loose Square
so B3 played
and it looks like yeah white just
completely collapses down two Pawns
another oh no my Bishop
this time white takes it
someone call an ambulance
but not for Fabiano caruana
what a nice mate a staff organic victory
oh this makes me so happy
I guilt-tripped one of the top players
in the world to play a really bad
opening and he he fully delivered he won
with it good job safaviano
I think we can say
uh the chest drama is over